the range of Modi's recent visit to
Israel the first ever by an Indian Prime
Minister marks India's transformation
from reflected hostility to a close
partnership with the Jewish state what
security and trade have driven the
change
there's also another often overlooked
freedom within India the Left lost the
argument
India opposed the 1948 creation of
Israel at the UN and didn't establish
full diplomatic relations until 1992
both international and domestic
considerations shaped India stance
diplomats worried about offending Arab
countries politicians worried about
offending Muslim voters so these would
reflect the deeper shift in public
opinion many middle class Indians now
view Israel not as a neo-colonial
oppressor but as Americans do as a
plucky country in a tough neighborhood
some are also attracted to the ancient
sense of Jewish culture which like
Hinduism predates Islam and Christianity
the Israeli Foreign Ministry found India
to be the most pro-israel of the
countries it's survey ahead of even the
u.s. close ties with Israel makes sense
to middle class Indians today the notion
of slowing down or underplaying India
Israel ties finds cute acres outside
India's rapidly dwindling left to learn
more about my take on India Israel size
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI